мій гість цього тижня свого часу був
одними з найвизначніших представників
російської еліти з впливовими зв'язками
Сергій гурєєв один із провідних
російських економістів керував кращими
економічним вишив країни його переобрали
до наглядової ради Збербанку але 10
років тому він несподівано втік з Росії
до Франції побоюючись за свою безпеку
економічні санкції обмежують можливості
Путіна вбивати українців висідати
в останні місяці Путін насилу знаходить
кошти на купівлю технології для
виробництва зброї та артилерійських
снарядів
Ця війна не про економіку результат цієї
війни буде вирішено на полі бою зараз
будучи професором економіки та
проректором паризького інституту
політичних досліджень він займається
вивченням того як виживають авторитарні
режими подібні до путінського як він
оцінює здатність Путіна утримувати Владу
і як довго Путін зможе фінансувати свою
війну на Теліги військових невдач і
санкцій
[музика]
Сергій єгурієв Вітаю вас у конфлікт Zone
дякую за запрошення
бойові дії та вторгнення в Україну
тривають уже другий рік як довго ще
Путін зможе фінансувати цю війну
Це залежить від багатьох факторів які
нам часто невідомі Путін уже стикнувся з
серйозними фінансовими обмеженнями коли
у грудні оголосили про нафтові санкції
було досить пізно але краще пізно ніж
ніколи
тепер фінансування війни дається йому
складно однак і зараз він має багато
ресурсів у тому числі і ті які він
накопичив у 2022 році
коли захід заморозив активи Центрального
банку Росії але продовжив купувати
російську нафту і газ даючи Путіну гроші
і все ж таки ми бачимо що в останні
місяці Путін насилу знаходить кошти на
купівлю технологій для виробництва зброї
та артилерійських снарядів
тому бачимо Що наприклад За останні
півроку лінія фронту практично не
змінилася І це також вплив економічних
санкцій
економічний санкції обмежують можливості
Путіна вбивати українців
тоді скажіть Путін використовує резерви
своєї країни щоб закрити діру в бюджеті
і ви згадали що більше частина з цих
трьохсот мільярдів доларів уже
заморожена санкціями як скоро на вашу
думку гроші закінчаться гроші до яких
він має доступ
цемент
Це не зовсім Ясно бо багато економічних
даних зараз засекречено Путіним ми не
знаємо наприклад наскільки добре
функціонує нині банківська система якщо
в банківській системі ще є велика
кількість готівки то Путін може брати
кредити у російських банків і
продовжувати фінансувати війну також
неясно за якою ціною він купує військові
технології через третій країни Туреччину
Індію Китай Казахстан Емірати багато з
цих даних нам невідомі але ми бачимо що
буквально кожен додатковий мільярд який
Він отримує він витрачає на купівлю
зброї на набір солдатів і тому в даному
конкретному випадку я сказав би що війна
триватиме доти доки Путін перебуває при
владі але інтенсивність цієї війни
скільки ще буде вбито українських
солдатів українських цивільних осіб
скільки ще буде зруйновано українських
міст залежить від того скільки грошей ми
йому дозволимо але ми бачимо що протягом
останніх місяців інтенсивність обстрілів
на лінії фронту значно знизилася і ми
бачимо що саме путінські солдати та
генерали і сам Путін почали говорити про
артилерійський голод у них нестача
боєприпасів у них не вистачає снарядів
щоби вбивати українців і це вже добре Ми
також бачимо що знизилося інтенсивність
використання ракет які завдавали ударів
по українській енергосистемі і в цьому
сенсі грудневі нафтові санкції і лютневі
санкції щодо нафтопродуктів виявилося
досить ефективними
говорячи про економіку в цілому ви
знаєте що санкції повинні були призвести
до макроекономічної нестабільності І ви
вже говорили про зниження ВВП яке
виявилося меншим за очікуване Мені
цікаво чи справило на вас враження як
добре російський центральний банк
впорався з наслідками санкцій
коли люди побачили запровадження
безпрецедентних санкцій проти
російського Центрального банку
Наприкінці лютого фактично на третій
день війни багато експертів подумали що
Росія піде шляхом Ірану чи Венесуели
зазнає великою макроекономічної
катастрофи ці санкції були
безпрецедентними і тому вони породили
безпрецедентні нереалістичні очікування
Але російська макроекономічна команда Як
ви сказали набагато компетентніша ніж
провідні банкіри та Міністерство
фінансів в інших країнах що Потрапили
під санкції Таким чином російський
центральний банк упорався з інфляцією
впорався з відпливом капіталу та
фактично уникнув макроекономічного
колапсу при цьому я маю сказати що
російська економіка перебуває в рецесії
і це незважаючи на дуже високу ціну на
нафту яка зазвичай дуже хороша для
російської економіки незважаючи на висо
ку ціну на нафту яку ми спостерігали
Минулого року Якщо ви подивитеся на
якість та рівень життя на споживчі
витрати то ці цифри становлять мінус
10%. Це незвично А як ситуація виглядає
з цієї росіян Міністр закордонних справ
Росії Лавров заявив що план заходу щодо
ізоляції Росія зазнав Фіаско Він сказав
що країна зміцнює добру сусідські
відносини з більшістю країн чи є в цьому
хоч частка Правди нещодавно лідер Китаю
стояв поряд із Путіним під час свого
державного візиту багато країн
глобального півдня зокрема в Африці для
яких Росія є великим експортером зброї
відмовилися засудити вторгнення в
Україну
Якщо ви подивитеся на голосування в ООН
побачити що багато країн утрималися Але
тих хто безпосередньо підтримав Росію
дуже мало І ми говоримо про Сирію ретрею
Нікарагуа буквально п'ять країн які
висловили підтримку Росії тепер про
Китай це надзвичайно важливо Я дуже
радий що Китай не постачає зброю Росії
якби Китай вирішив надати Наскільки нам
відомо
Наскільки нам відомо так але якби Пекін
хотів дотримуватися цієї ідеї безмежної
дружби то він надав би Москві зброю без
обмежень і готівку без обмежень і
санкції не працювали Зараз ми бачимо що
Росія змушена купувати боєприпаси та
зброю в Ірану та Північної Кореї якість
яких небагато нижче ніж якість
китайської зброї та технології Тож ми
бачимо що російсько-китайська дружба має
певні межі і більше того після від'їзду
слід дзвінкіна ви знаєте було інтерв'ю
посла Китаю до ЄС який сказав що дружба
без обмежень - це риторика і Китай не
підтримує порушення територіального
суверенітету і цілісності України тож
тут є нюанси так Китай не є союзником
заходу в цій війні у цій війні Індія
продовжує купувати російську нафту але
все ж таки не варто говорити як сказав
міністр Лавров що решта світу більшість
світу підтримує Росію це неправда це
з економічної точки зору як ми вже
говорили Росія робить своєрідний
розворот Путін каже що він шукає ринки
дружніх країн Куди він може
переорієнтувати постачання енергоносіїв
як далеко на вашу думку можуть зайти цей
партнерства з підтримки Путіна та
російської економіки головне питання
полягає в тому чи дотримується інші
країни і рішення щодо стелі цін на нафту
ви згадали обмеження нафтових цін
запроваджене заходом нині це
найважливіше питання захід сказав Ми
хочемо зберегти російську нафту на ринку
тому ми будемо раді якщо Індія
купуватиме російську нафту Чому Тому що
якщо російська нафта піде зі світового
ринку на нафтовому ринку почнеться криза
ціни на нафту зростуть тому мета заходу
мета обмеження нафтових цін полягає в
тому щоб Індія купувала російську нафту
але купувала її за низькою ціною тоді
Путіну не вистачить грошей щоб
продовжувати фінансувати цю війну
повертаючись до нашого першого запитання
якщо Кринична ціна на нафту буде 60
Путін не матиме достатнього грошей щоб
збалансувати свій бюджет і продовжувати
війну з високою інтенсивністю якщо
гранична ціна на нафту буде знижена є
сподіваюся що це відбудеться цього року
з 60 до 55 з 55 до 60 Росія матиме все
менше і менше грошей доки решта світу
зокрема Індія платитиме за російську
нафту менше це ключове питання поки що
ми бачимо що Індія купує більше
російської нафти але російський бюджет
при цьому у Великому дефіциті тож схоже
Цей підхід справді працює наскільки
економічне становище в Росії погіршиться
щоб позиції Путіна похитнулися
в тому сенсі що в нього недостатньо
зброї щоб захопити Бахмут це триває вже
півроку півроку зрештою Ця війна не про
економіку результат цієї війни буде
вирішено на полі бою
відзначили зниження рівня споживчих
витрат наприклад Минулого року на
скільки сильно домогосподарства
відчувають цей спад і чи може це
вилитися у реальний спротив суспільства
Кремлю
ми цього не знаємо тому що ми говоримо
про момент коли суспільство зрозуміє що
так більше не може продовжуватися і це
призведе до нас свого протесту поліція
приєднається до протестувальників це те
що передбачити дуже важко Путін дуже
хвилюється з цього приводу Він платить
дедалі більше умону Він не надсилає ОМОН
в Україну Він шукає солдатів серед
цивільних він не використовує
Національну гвардію для війни тому що
Нацгвардія потрібна йому для побиття
потенційних протестувальників якщо
уявити що ви живете в Німеччині чи
Великобританії якість вашого життя падає
на 10%, то на вулицях почнуться масові
протести у Росія все інакше якщо ви
протестуєте в Росії вас б'ють катують і
садять у в'язницю на 10 років а у
випадку із Володимиром карам морзою 25
років в’язниці за відкритий виступ проти
війни тож це дуже репресивна держа ва це
не Росія 2020 року це не Росія 2013 року
це зовсім інша країна наразі ми говоримо
про такий рівень репресій якого не
бачили з радянських часів
ви багато писали Про стиль керівництва
Путіна понад 20 років тому Путін приїхав
до Берліна і виголосив дуже відому
промову німецькою мовою перед
бундестагом де він сказав що холодна
війна закінчилася що це було просто фарс
Як ви вважаєте чи завжди був у нього
генеральний план спрямований на
створення імперії чи його цілі змінилися
з часом
думаю про це зараз можна лише гадати ми
знаємо що він завжди був корупціонером
він керував своїм оточенням як босмафії
тому Як тільки він прийшов у Кремль він
почав будувати свій палац у генджику
Чорноморський палац ми знаємо що він
відразу ж запровадив усі ці схеми Тож
він не будує імперії він радше будує
палаци А це зовсім інша річ але Згодом
він зрозумів що для того щоб охороняти
свої палаци А в нього їх близько 20 чи
не так Йому потрібно створити на
побудови імперії відновлення радянської
імперії
якщо ви повторюєте цей наратив протягом
10 років То врешті-решт ви самі
починаєте вірити в нього і гадаю зараз
він сам у це вірить але починав він з
ідеї живий Та дай жити умовно кажучи я
будую свої палаци але може економічне
зростання буде настільки сильним що всі
змиряться із моєю корупцією із
централізацією влади але зрештою коли
економічне зростання зупинилося А було
очевидно що так воно і буде він подумав
Мені потрібен новий наратив і тому він
анексував Крим він сказав росіянам
знаєте у вас не буде зростання доходів
але ви будете частиною імперії і звісно
велику роль відіграла пандемія протягом
двох років Путін був дуже ізольований
він спілкувався лише з кількома людьми
які лише підкріплювали його про
імперський антизахідний наратив і я
думаю що зараз він і сам у це вірить
Ви також писали Про те як Путін прийшов
до влади у 2000 році ви кажете що він
працював над збереженням видимості
демократії але коли він повернувся до
президентства у 2012 році його програма
дій змінилася вона більше нагадувала
правління шляхом залякування правління
страху Чи це було неминуче і що
змінилося що змінилося то це те що у
перші 10 років Він правив під час
безпрецедентного економічного зростання
російська економіка Практично подвоїлася
за перші 10 років правління Путіна і ось
він створив цей соціальний договір за
яким він користувався популярністю бо
забезпечував зростання доходів зростання
зарплат зростання споживання і всіх це
влаштовувало а потім оскільки він був
корумпований і не хотів мати систему
стримувань та противаг не хотів мати
демократичний підзвітність економічне
зростання зійшло нанівець і якщо ви
просто поглянете на цифри то побачите що
ми мали значне падіння ВВП у році під
час світової економічної кризи потім
економіка відновилася до кризового рівня
а потім вона перестала зростати бо
економікою керувала держава умівській
капіталізм друзі Путіна контролювали всю
економіку тому йому потрібен був новий
наратив цей стало головною зміною це
було неминуче але це також був і вибір
Путіна не проводити реформи не боротися
з корупцією не дозволити державі стати
прозорою Та добре керованою і зрештою це
призвело до того що він зробив анексував
Крим зайняв антизахідні позиції і почав
поступово нарощувати рівень репресій ви
сказали що пу побудував режим таким
чином що без нього ця система працювати
не зможе І що на вашу думку зрештою вона
розвалиться Як довго може протриматися
Путін і що станеться згодом якщо він
впадеться
система побудована на особистості
Володимира Путіна він хоче дати
зрозуміти своєму оточенню що вони не
зможуть без нього функціонувати вони
вбиватимуть один одного вони знищать
один одного Якщо Путін зникне що означає
Путін смертна людина і він не молодий
коли його не стане система має змінитись
як Спочатку вони намагатимуться
координувати свої дії між собою але
Зрештою вони побачать що ні в кого з них
немає харизми Путіна Ніхто з них не має
справжньої підтримки з боку населення Не
забувайте що Путін має певну базу
підтримки тому що він керував
економічним процвітанням перші десять
років перебування при владі і тому що
отримати цю підтримку населення вони або
встановлять щось на кшталт
північнокорейського режиму з
найжорсткішими репресіями є сумніваюся
що це спрацює бо Росія - це не Північна
Корея Це набагато складніше промислово
розвинене та освічене суспільство або їм
знадобиться економічне процвітання і для
цього їм доведеться вести переговори із
заходом та Україною щодо зняття санкцій
тож ми побачимо щось на зразок нової
перебудови Якщо Путін піде чи помре
Путін чи вб'ють його чи відсторонніх від
влади це дуже складне запитання
відповідь на яке дати вкрай важко але
якщо Путін програє війну в Україні
наприклад якщо Путін втратить Крим це
різко зменшить його шанси залишитися при
владі бо він поставив на цю війну все що
мав на демократичні режими змінюються
непередбачуваним чином і все ж таки це
система побудована на Путіні Як тільки
він піде система зміниться як
суспільство зможе переробити та
переосмислити жахи вчинені в Україні чи
є у вас надія що не відбудуться
найближчим часом
простим цей процес не буде ви зараз
перебуваєте в Німеччині Німеччина
пройшла через це після 1945 року і це
було нелегко все сталося не одразу і не
було чітко Зрозуміло Як це зробити
правильно але зараз Німеччина вільна
демократична Мирна країна деякі люди
навіть сказали що надто Мирна Але я
думаю що Німеччина впоралася з цим інші
країни теж впоралися Росія не є
генетично неповноцінною той хто говорить
що Росія завжди залишиться автократичною
русофоб та расист сподіваюся що ми
зможемо відновити країну та створити
війну демократичну про європейську Росію
Сергій югорієв Дякую за ваш час і за те
що приєдналися до нас на конфлікт
[музика]